if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
well i always talk about the proposition
as being my favorite film of the films
that i've done and i probably still feel
that way um i've certainly been part of
some great
stories absolutely no question about it
um obviously things like l.a
confidential and priscilla and momento
are ones for people to take a look at
but i think there's something about the
proposition that
feels more personal
uh i don't know if it's because it's
australian as well
um
and it's just a really evocative film
there's just something about
there's something about filmmaking and
that film that that
that that work really well together no
question about the filmmaking abilities
of curtis hanson in early confidential
and certainly chris nolan in memento but
as i say there's just something
really visceral and effective about the
proposition
if i'm not mistaken uh didn't nick cave
write that
or am i wrong
nick cave did write that and he also did
the music for it yeah yeah i was going
to say that that maybe there's something
about nick's involvement also that makes
it special
he his involvement absolutely makes it
special um but it is the it's the
culmination of everything it's john
hilcode's directing and and
it it feels like
you're inside a nick cave song
so yes you're absolutely right him
having penned that story i think
is unique makes it unique you touched on
memento i've heard about people that
have done edits of memento so they watch
it in order have you heard about this
i haven't heard about people doing edits
uh with the film itself but i know that
there are versions of the script out
there that are that are um well in fact
maybe i did know that there was a
version where you can watch it as an
extra on a dvd thing where you can watch
it in order i think i might have known
that actually sorry i just lied
uh i've never watched it in order i just
think that it's it's fascinating but
anyway um of the films that you've made
which one do you think changed the most
in the editing room versus what you were
expecting
well um i did a film called uh
till human voices wake us
which
was a series of present and past
sort of elements me as a young boy with
a young girl and then me as an older man
uh with that young girl had died in the
story and so me as an older man with the
ghost of that woman with me who helena
bottom carter played
and in the
i actually trying to remember now
but i think in the script it really
flashed back and forth back and forth
back and forth i think
but in the finished film it was
completely the kid's story and then it
was our story and there was just
something about it that just didn't work
as it should have
and it's funny talking about memento on
the opposite end of the spectrum i've
never done a film
that has ended up as exactly like the
script
as that film
every film has some version of
reordering things usually or a couple of
scenes taken out or you know expanded on
this scene and gotten rid of that one
etc and you know even to the point
sometimes where they'll change the order
of scenes and you go but i was wearing a
blue shirt now i'm wearing a red shirt
and now i'm wearing the blue shirt again
because you've taken that scene from
then and you've plonked it in there you
know so that sort of stuff happens
memento is exactly like the script was
yeah this nolan guy he's gonna have a
career
you know exactly oh yeah that i think
the guy directed it yeah he was all
right actually
exactly um uh what's the most you've
actually prepared for one of your roles
and which role
well probably andy warhol um
for factory girl and that sort of came
about
sadly
because of uh hurricane katrina
um because we had we were meant to film
the film in new orleans
we had all gone to new york to start
rehearsals and then katrina happened
so the film got held up for about six or
so weeks i think while they then figured
out where in louisiana they could do the
film
and they moved it to shreveport
meanwhile i was in new york getting to
meet all the people from the warhol
world who i could meet and and spend
time with them and preparing etc so that
became an elongated
preparation
um
but was utterly fascinating um
so i would say that film and that
character
um if you have not seen the six part
warhol dock that's now on netflix i just
finished it recently and it's
fascinating it's fantastic i saw it on
there and i was and i thought oh
and then a part of me went oh
can i go back into that world do i need
to go back into that world i really want
to go back into that world but i i sort
of have to be prepared for it because it
is a world that i i
indulged in but i think i probably will
check it out yes
it's it's very good and i think warhol
would enjoy the way that the they used a
computer to recreate his voice
um and uh i'm just recommending it it's
very good okay okay i'll check it out
thank you you know um so uh uh
what do you remember when you think back
on count of monte cristo what do you
remember about that movie is that when
you look back fondly
well
i had good times and bad times on it uh
when i first turned up in in ireland i
was handed a new version of the script
which was very different to the one i
signed on to so that was that then
became a challenge to to get it back or
get my character at the very least back
to
what i'd originally agreed to do
um
and that was quite the test
uh but once we did and once we got going
and once it was
you know once i put my foot down about
what i wanted to do um
it it was a bit of a struggle but i at
least had a good time kevin was a great
guy jim kavisa was a great guy
you know dagumara
james frain luis guzman of course henry
cavill all these lovely people that i
got to work with
um
uh helen mccrory who sadly you know
passed away last year um
so
so i had a lovely time with these great
people and then we also got to go to
malta and film in malta so there was
some really extraordinary sort of parts
of it as well and a great story to tell
of course
um freddie jones who who was in my
favorite film of all time in the
elephant man
so getting to work with him was amazing
although he was quite grumpy so i didn't
really get much out of him
[Laughter]
uh
never meet your heroes as they say um
so yeah i have fond memories but it was
it was a it was a tough bit of a tough
one to begin with as well yeah
jumping into why i get to talk to you um
what is it about liam neeson that people
love watching him punch people in the
face
[Laughter]
well because he's a big ex-boxer and i
reckon they know that that punch is
actually going to really you know
they're going to believe it there's no
question that if if he's if he's after
you you're in trouble
um also i think
he exudes a real
sort of sensitivity and humanity and so
you know he's not just a typical action
hero he's a he's a he's a humane
sensitive guy but has a tough brutal
side and so that's the whole package
going aft you know if if someone like
that is going after somebody it's it's
not the same as just a typical action
hero who who doesn't really have much in
the way of chops um what was it actually
listen i'm a big fan of liam's work um
what was it actually yeah what was it
actually like working with him i know
it's such a generic question but like i
am actually curious well it was
delightful i mean he he couldn't be
nicer he's exactly my kind of guy i
think i'm his kind of guy you know we we
we think the same way we work the same
way we just want to get on with it we
don't want any of the sort of [ __ ]
that goes with you know wasting time etc
um
we're both quite cheeky we both love a
good laugh um
but but also you know want to do good
work
um so that balance of all of that stuff
i think meant that
we connected very quickly very easily um
and and have remained sort of good mates
and keep messaging each other silly
stuff ever since then to be honest
uh it's so interesting though because
obviously i've spoken to so many actors
through the years and you know everyone
has a different process and some
people's processes do not gel with other
people's work and you really never know
until you get on set how it's going to
go no i had a feeling that it would be
good with liam because he and i share an
agent and and my agent talked so fondly
of him and had always said you two are
going to get on like a house on fire so
i i always and i'd met liam before
briefly so i just knew that it would be
good um but i wasn't sure if he you know
needed a new friend or not so i didn't
want to pester him
but i think once
once he saw that i wasn't there to be a
pain in the bum or waste anybody's time
he was very happy to you know
spend time chatting so
so yeah we had a lovely time it was
great i'm obviously a fan of martin
campbell um and what's interesting about
martin is the way he likes to shoot
action i know he really takes an
interest in it um and it's something
that he's always trying to find you know
do it realistically and um i've spoken
to him about it um what did you find
about working with martin uh what can
you share about the experience well just
you know just that he's so energetic
he's so kind of fit and energetic but
particularly for a guy of his age so i i
kind of felt like well you know i got to
keep up with him so that that was the
as well as being
really nuanced and sort of subtle and
wanting to make sure that the character
stuff works um
i i realized that i was in the hands of
somebody who whose ability with action
is is really um
proficient and
you know just as i say just sort of with
with great ex he brings great experience
and and it
it's hard to explain but you know when
when a director says right the camera is
going to be here and you're going to run
past here and this is how i'm going to
shoot this thing
okay wow that's interesting yeah okay so
you get the sense that he's innovative
um
so yeah i loved working with him and you
know as a fellow antibiotic and we got
on very well as well
uh something else is in this role you
get to play the honest cop um which you
know uh um you've played obviously
police officers before but uh i guess
what was it about this role that said oh
i really want to do this
well it's the you know the
i think one of the things a number of
things but one of the things i suppose
was that he's all he's also carrying a
bit of a personal
sort of
tragedy in his history um and trying not
to let that get in the way of his work
so i feel like there was something about
him being at the end of his tether you
know being
sort of cynical and a bit bruised and
and and but trying not to let that um
wear him down or affect his work so so
that i really liked um
and i liked the
the way in which these two men
wanted to connect with each other even
though they come from different worlds
and they're they're different they have
very different jobs
um i think there was something about
humanity
in the two of them as i say that meant
they sort of wanted to make contact with
each other
and of course in the end we realized
they're both sort of fighting for the
same thing
um
so so that i found quite appealing as
well
yeah
i definitely i won't lie i definitely
had a chuckle when liam is writing stuff
on his arm and you are in this movie
yeah i i didn't because because i wasn't
there when he was uh when he was filming
that so i had no idea that he did that
uh and then i saw the trailer and went
oh
wait a minute but of course everybody
writes things on their hands or on their
arm or whatever so it's a you know but
because of a certain iconic film
it's hard to go past
i should have been in the background of
that shot and gun wait a minute
it really it really made me chuckle i'm
like of course guys in this movie you
know what i mean um uh what's like a day
or two you'll always remember from
filming um maybe with something you did
with liam i'm sure there's like always a
day or two from every film when you
think back like that's the thing that
you remember
well i mean i have a big monologue in
the in the middle of the film in the
hospital room where i'm talking to him
and i finally get sort of blurred out of
my cynicism about justice and i
obviously tell this story about my wife
and my child that he that i don't say is
my wife and my child but he picks up on
it
and that to me is this whole central
point of or the whole central
uh drive of my character
so selfishly that's
what i feel like i kind of
centered everything around so that's
what i sort of remember the most
um
yeah as far as other stuff
uh
i don't really know it all becomes a bit
of a blur to be honest i'd really just
focus and remember working with liam in
that hospital room because that's when
the two
the two guys kind of
uh find some sort of compassion for each
other i think
yeah no i mean i i completely understand
when i speak to a lot of actors i'm
really fascinated about the process and
so say you have a scene like that where
it's like an emotional scene you're
doing a you know delivering
a monologue that's important to you and
to your performance um how early on are
you actually preparing for that
monologue and for that scene is it like
a few days before is it no no no no it's
it's as but as soon as the film starts
i'm a slow learner and particularly with
the monologue
particularly with something so pivotal
um i need to know it in my bones really
really really well otherwise i'm too
sort of anxious about it
and if there's going to be any changes
to dialogue i need that to be sorted out
sooner rather than later because that
really freaks me out if the day before
people are saying here the new pages you
know i just don't i have no respect for
that way of working
uh and i don't like it and i don't feel
i'm respected if that's what ends up
happening so
you know my my
my biggest task on any film is to learn
my lines
um
and if i don't get to learn my lines
then i'm not a happy boy
so
um you know i i always just say please
do me the respect of if there's going to
be any changes
and there comes a point where i go well
i'm now in charge of this i'm now in
charge of whether there's going to be
any changes or not because i'm the one
saying it so if you want me to add
something you should have done it three
weeks ago sorry
no it's so interesting because uh
again i've spoken to so many people who
have like you know they're working on a
movie and by the end of the shoot it's
like a rainbow script you know with how
many changes well and that's fair enough
like it's totally fair enough i totally
get it like
particularly because
you know you might shoot something that
then
you realize actually tells a certain
part of the story and you go well we
don't need that in this later one so
we've got to take those three lines out
later or you know this isn't really
going to be enough we've got to inject
more of that element in the story later
so we've got to add some yellow pages
and red pages and green pages we've got
it so i totally get it and i totally
respect it
but when it comes to a monologue when it
comes to a big chunk of stuff it just
takes me a while to learn it so i i
and i need to know it in the same way
when i used to do theater
you have four weeks rehearsing it and
it's over and you know it so well
that that's when i start to really feel
like i own it and i can and i can do my
best work with it otherwise i'm going
what's my next line what's my next line
what's my next line and i'm not
performing well yeah it's uh i would be
in your boat in terms of i would be a
very slow learner and i would need to
um i would need to own it as you said
like yeah you know what i mean as early
as you can because i wouldn't be able to
learn lines the day before and feel like
i was effective at delivering them
emotionally no i'm i'm yeah exactly that
and i never understood in the old days
it was really tricky when if you if you
had an audition
uh or a reading on tape and they would
give you this you know they would say
okay so here's the script you can just
read it on camera you know and i think
you want me to read and act at the same
time
that's just not going to happen it does
i don't yeah i don't know how that's
true i don't know how the people can get
the although who knows i i don't know
the casting process some people can do
that but not me
um i'm looking forward to him looking
down just to be honest um a spy among
friends you're doing with damian lewis
yes i just finished a few weeks ago and
it's it's glorious yeah i'm really i'm a
huge fan of his work i'm obviously a
huge fan of your work so this is one
that i'm like oh i am paying attention
um what what can you say about it oh
it's it's really classy nick murphy
directed it who i worked with on a
christmas carol um
and
it's it's just it's spectacular it's
really spectacular
it's based on a ben mcintyre book which
is fantastic ben's of ben's a wonderful
writer but alex carey who wrote the
script has done the most wonderful job i
can't i can't speak highly enough about
it
it's it's glorious yeah if i'm not
mistaken and i i could be wrong but i
think you play a double agent
or
damien
no i play kim philby so he is one of um
who were famously known as the cambridge
five
um who were five
um
students of cambridge university who
later on through their life
who either ended up working for mi6 or
mi5 or
um
all were
sort of double agents and and working
for russian intelligence
uh soviet intelligence and philby was
sort of the most notorious of them all
um and defected in 1963 so from
1934 right through till 1963 when he
defected and moved went to russia you
know escaped to russia and never came
back
uh he had been working for russian
intelligence it's an incredible story
a lot of people know
the story of the cambridge five but this
story focuses mainly on kim philby and
his closest friend nicholas elliot who
damien plays and the betrayal of that
friendship more than just the betrayal
of the country
is it a six-part eight-part series what
is it six
six um
so do you know when it's coming out
i think they're looking at the end of
the year i think they're i think they're
looking at november but i maybe don't
quite be on that i'm not entirely sure i
i yeah i'm just wondering when i can
actually see it and i'm looking at the
calendar and i'm like oh end of the year
um uh so what's this infernal machine
also is that something you filmed
yes the infernal machine was a was a
fantastic really fantastic script uh
that andrew hunt wrote and directed his
first film as a writer director uh well
first film in this sort of of this scale
um
he's an american uh
and we shot the film in portugal even
though it's set uh on the sort of
californian
mexican border
um
really clever film about a uh
a writer who had written one famous book
20 odd years ago and
he's now sort of being
hounded by a fan
uh which begins to turn his world upside
down he's sort of
a recluse and you know his world is sort
of being turned upside down by this
either fan or whatever it is um but just
a really clever fantastic script yeah
i'm looking forward to that it's so
interesting that uh they just neil
jordan uh just filmed with liam uh marlo
in like
not maybe not portugal but like spain or
madrid and that's supposed to take place
in 1930s los angeles
you know
well i mean even memory we shot in
bulgaria
yeah it's uh but it's just funny that
los angeles is madrid spain you know
because of the architecture or whatever
um so i'm so curious about that uh i
think i'm almost out of time with you
but i'm so curious what did what do you
wish someone had told you early in your
career
about making movies and what you need to
know that perhaps you learned throughout
your career
and the thing that sort of and it was
not so much about my work and my career
i guess it's more just my own personal
thing about having grown up feeling
really anxious about
about everything just being a person
full of anxiety i wish someone could
have helped me
alleviate or dilute some of that earlier
on um
but i don't know i don't i don't
necessarily
feel that there are things that i
wish had that i'd done differently or
i'd learnt earlier on i kind of feel i
feel like i've had a really blessed
incredible career i've been really lucky
you know i just got lucky you know
and because there are wonderful actors
out there who don't get the
opportunities that i've had so
i i
and i and i'm certainly somebody who's
always
been very grateful and i don't take
things for granted um so
i don't feel like i've wasted the
opportunities that i've had um
so i feel like
i i've managed to sort of handle it all
right even though i had really hard
times but
i'm not sure if there's a bit of
advice or something i could have learned
that i wished i'd learned earlier on i'm
not sure
yeah it's it's so interesting because i
i agree that you can be a great actor
but there there is an element of luck
that you know with the business in terms
of you know who gets through because
it's absolutely i mean i think and it's
funny because i meet young actors and
talk to young actors and i see that sort
of eagerness about you know how do i how
do i become like how do i get to where
you how do i you know and the thing that
i just always want to say to them is
just is just stop
being so eager
like and not not that they will but it's
not that for me to say but
the eagerness is not going to help
anyway
uh and i don't know that i was that
eager i was i was too sort of insecure i
feel like in a weird way i shouldn't
have got through at all because i i you
know i was clearly ambitious i suppose
and i had an interest in it
but i
i wasn't sort of
and i don't know if i noticed it more
now particularly with young australian
actors because they know that there's a
clear path to hollywood whereas in the
old days you know particularly in my day
and before there was no path to
hollywood
you know it was only there was only
three actors i think you'd ever gone to
hollywood from australia so it was just
it was just nigh impossible the prospect
of it and the funniest thing russell
crowe ever said to me was that he and i
were the last two off the bridge before
they took the toll off the bridge
you know so they just sort of the
floodgates open so now i meet these
young australian actors who are like i'm
going to hollywood how do i get to
hollywood hollywood hollywood and i'm
like wow just do some work at home first
like just slow down just
hone the craft do some theater you know
so i thankfully i'm thankful that i'm
not
i'm thankful that i'm through and i'm
sort of managing to to to work all over
the world and and get to choose a lot of
the work that i get to choose
yeah
i just read uh and i have to rap but um
i just read that they are opening this
brand new state of the art
um the biggest led you know the
mandalorian like the technology they use
on that they're opening the biggest
version of that technology in australia
i just read the press release this
morning for oh really for um
sam s mills sci-fi metropolis series uh
we just did a we just did one in inspire
among friends we did one big scene using
that technology uh on a sort of a
rooftop in a studio that was meant to be
beirut around us and we did a sort of a
10-page scene between damien and i using
that technology it was quite amazing
yeah they also used it on the batman
it's it's unbelievable you know like
it's it's as long as you get the
lighting right and you have that plate
behind you that looks real it you it's
amazing yeah yeah it makes you a bit
because the background moves when the
camera moves the background moves so
you're there going whoa hang on you can
get a bit travel sick if you're not
careful i've heard i've heard that
listen i gotta go um i gotta
you know like the cut has come and i'm
just gonna say listen thank you so much
for your time uh and i you know as
always anything i can do to help on
collider please let me know
thank you
thank you man look out for yourself
you